أتساءل إنني أعلم أنك لا تريد التحدث عن
السياسة اليوم ، ولكن ما إذا كان لديك
رد فعل على نوع التغريدات غير المرغوب فيها
التي صدرت من الولايات المتحدة
من نجل الرئيس دونالد ترامب جونيور.
بالإشارة إلى مقابلة أجريتها
قبل أشهر وتقول إنك يجب أن
تمزح معي
فيما يتعلق بتكرار أو
احتمالية الإرهاب في المدن الكبرى
اليوم ، حسنًا ، لن أرد على
تغريدة من دونالد ترامب جونيور.  كنت أقوم
بأشياء أكثر أهمية بكثير خلال الـ
24 ساعة الماضية ، ما أعرفه هو أن
مستوى التهديد في لندن وفي جميع أنحاء
البلاد شديد ، وهذا يعني أنه من
المحتمل جدًا أن أكون في نيويورك
العام الماضي عندما كان هناك هجوم في
نيويورك و  الإرهابيون يكرهون حقيقة
أنه سواء كنت أنت أو لندن
سواء كانت باريس معنا بروكسل
سواء كانت اسطنبول معنا مدريد
لدينا مجتمعات متنوعة تعيش
معًا بسلام